and our week-long series were calling it
world of weddings I love this series
we're traveling all around the world
reporting on unique ceremonies and
looking at what marriage means in
different countries so today we're going
to South Africa was recently as the
1980s mixed-race marriages were illegal
under apartheid now couples are allowed
to choose who they marry but the
different backgrounds can bring some
challenges you could say Debora patta
went to Pretoria to explore one of those
weddings this is a true celebration of
love across racial and cultural barriers
but although apartheid is over in South
Africa weddings like this one are still
the exception to the norm two worlds
collide as the masalas and the Daltons
come together for the marriage of their
children Monta and Andrew the groom's
mother hazel Dalton wipes away tears
nobody underestimates the importance of
this moment
[Applause]
celebrating love across the color line
once outlawed and punishable by prison
this would have been unimaginable in
apartheid South Africa my grandmother
who unfortunately isn't here to this day
she was more excited than anyone else
because she's like this is exactly or
Nelson Mandela for for it's also a
celebration across cultural lines
they're here to negotiate a bride price
known as la bola traditionally a means
to cement ties between two families
vantes paddy
one of South Africa's many ethnic groups
Andrews families from England labora is
a centuries-old tradition that used to
be paid in cattle but that's a little
complicated in these modern times at
first I was a little bit skeptical
because obviously again something's new
to me but you have to go and with no up
in mind and you have to respect the
culture and the family and and at the
end of the day if I want to marry Monty
that's something I'm going to have to do
the final amount is confidential a young
well-educated woman like Monta could
easily fetch up to 15 cows the
equivalent of just over $10,000 but as
Monta gets ready she acknowledges it's
not always easy being a modern couple
navigating traditional African customs
we're just doing what we need to do in
this period to make our parents happy
and then we go back to our normal lives
where we don't have to fall into the
gender role right now though she has
more pressing concerns but I'm also
nervous nervous dancing there's a
thoughtful it's like he misplaced not to
Andrews heritage clearly nobody seems to
mind the Scotland and England are
completely different nations but for the
most part it is a thoroughly African
affair which includes being schooled in
how to be a good wife the traditional
ceremony is part of ten days of
festivities culminating in what many
would regard as a thoroughly modern
wedding at a wine farm outside Cape Town
this time it was very much Monta and
Andrews event their friends flew in from
around the world for the big day part
two
they were the usual wedding day nerves
and the bride's almost obligatory late
arrival followed by the joyful walk down
the aisle on her father's arm there two
of us the two of us are a united front
or a united front
do it go and then it was time to party
where Andrews dance moves were finally
put to the test
[Music]
for family friends like moody magic on a
who lived through apartheid there's even
more cause to celebrate love knows no
boundaries and because of love knows no
boundaries in those days love would no
boundaries because then you'd be
arrested for having it so it's a protest
day of malice and now three decades on
while weddings like this so still
unusual for Monte and Andrew it feels
completely natural they're just two
young people deeply in love for
Montaigne Andrew this is the joyous
beginning of their married life but for
the older generation this is so much
bigger another way in which Nelson
Mandela's dream of a non-racial society
is being realized for CBS this morning
I'm Debora patta in Pretoria South
Africa well they seem off to a good
start I love that the bride was
concerned about his dance moves good
dancing in South Africa is very big
dancing he passed the test I think he
gets an A for effort as well
diplomatically put and I love when the
minister said do it go yes very nice